Barack Obama has unveiled plans for his
Presidential Library and Museum on the
south side of Chicago according to an
Obama aide the presidential library will
have a children's play garden sledding
hill green spaces for picnics and
outdoor gatherings basketball courts in
a recording studio with the library will
not have our any books or documents is
there a more apt metaphor for the Obama
presidency we will explain Barack
Obama's empty library and legacy and
then the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
a lot to talk about today got to go
through Barack Obama's empty legacy and
dance on the grave of his political
priorities before we get to that we have
to talk about Skillshare because we
don't want to just destroy we don't want
to just bring people down we want to
build ourselves up as well
a Skillshare is a really really great
tool for this so it's January I know if
you're like me you come up with like a
dozen resolutions and then within seven
minutes you're gonna get rid of them and
not gonna do any of them while many
people have resolved to go on a diet hit
the gym call mom more often Skillshare
encourages listeners to use 2018 to
learn new skills and make this year
their best year yet Skillshare is a
phenomenal platform I really encourage
everybody to go use it it's an online
learning platform with over 18,000
classes in design business technology
and more so whether you're trying to
deepen your professional skill set start
a side hustle little side business or
just explore something new Skillshare
will keep you learning in 2018 and
beyond you know I've been an actor I've
worked in political campaigns for all of
my professional life and so everybody
has gigs all the time it's all just gigs
and you have to be able to hustle you
have to have a wide range of skills that
can apply to things I think this is true
in the economy right now and especially
for younger people you're not gonna just
stay one company for 60 years and then
retire get a pension so it's really
important to build up skills in a wide
variety of areas one area in particular
by the way if you're watching this you
probably use social media you probably
are technologically savvy I fritter away
all my time on Twitter a Twitter away
all my time and there are some great on
Skillshare you can check out some great
strategies for time management to put
off procrastination there really a lot
of really cool thing I couldn't get into
all of the classes now because it's
basically anything you would want to
learn you can you can go there and there
will be a class on it so just in time
for the New Year Skillshare is offering
the Michael Nolt show listeners for a
limited time an offer of three months of
Skillshare for just 99 cents you get
guys what are you doing go there right
now like it go there
this instant it is one dollar that I
think these days it's about a fifth of
what you pay for a cup of coffee at
Starbucks or something go to Skillshare
right now three months for just 99 cents
there's absolutely no reason not to do
it it's practically free to sign up go
to Skillshare comm / michael 99 that is
gonna be my rap name I think Michael 99
go to Michael 99 mi CH AE L 99 again
Skillshare comm / michael 99 to get
three months of Skillshare for only 99
cents act now this is a special New
Year's offer it is going to go away very
soon I can't tell you when you will know
not the day or the hour but just do it
now get yourself locked in at that price
and start learning today it's very
important to learn okay there won't be
any learning going on by the way at the
Barack Obama Presidential Library
because there aren't any books Martin
Nesbitt the chairman of the Obama
foundation explained the Obama
Presidential Center will be a global
community center a place of life and
vibrancy that showcases the South Side
to the world so there's a basketball
possibly a yoga room Test Kitchen to
teach visitors about the quote full
production cycle of nutritious food
there's a recording studio an auditorium
a sports facility a 235-foot tall tower
for some reason something I don't know
what they do in there 350 million
dollars to build 22 acres of land the
only thing I won't have are books or
documents now I didn't realize how old I
am it's a new year it's 2018 already I
am so old that I actually remember when
libraries contains books and documents
now presumably there will be computers
at this library or iPads or something so
they can at least Google some of the
terrible things that Barack Obama did
but if the lights go out that means that
the Obama library will be identical to
the Obama legacy and perhaps that's
really the brilliant artistic
engineering year form and content and
perfect harmony
the Obama library marks the decline of
our politics and culture just like the
Obama administration showed the decline
of our politics and culture even the
Chicago Tribune Obama's hometown
newspaper not exactly a bastion of
conservatism ran a headline asking
without archives on site how will Obama
Center benefit air
students and scholars the foundation CEO
David Simas explained this is going to
be completely different what the
president and first lady said is they
simply did not want a museum that served
as a mausoleum a way to look back this
is typical Obama typical Obama nice
arrogant and ambitious enough to want
constant change constant activism
turning presidential campaigns into a
permanent campaign fundamentally just
transforming America but it's completely
ignorant of history philosophy culture
disdainful of the past of the present
and of tradition itself Obama's papers
by the way are currently stored in a
private facility in the city and suburbs
of not Chicago Washington DC they sent
them all to Chicago spent a lot of money
doing and I said now we actually don't
want them at this fake library so they
go right back to DC this gets perfectly
to my theory of the left the left always
wants the appearance of the thing but
without the essence of the thing like
decaffeinated coffee or they or they
want hashtag activism so the where lapel
pins to the golden globes of dress and
black but they won't stop raping people
even their resistance movements are lazy
and hollow do you remember they didn't
they didn't March or protest or even
really petition anything after the
financial crisis they occupied Wall
Street they occupy a sat around and they
did nothing they didn't even stand they
occupied it the these lefties will
disrupt ben shapiro speeches civil
disobedience man but they won't show
their faces they'll wear masks because
if they showed their faces they would
have to experience consequences they
want to have libraries without any books
so anyway here's barack obama almost
beyond parody talking about his document
for your library i won't stop in fact i
will be right there with you
as a citizen all my remaining days the
single most important thing I can do is
to help prepare the next generation of
leadership to take their own track of
change in the world more than a library
or a museum it would be a living working
center for citizenship
we all have projects all over the city
the country and the world so many young
people to believe that you can make a
difference to hitch your wagon to
something bigger than yourself those
poor kids I feel sorry for them if
Barack Obama's teaching them leadership
because his legacy has been utterly
destroyed and think about that Messiah
Complex too I I will be with you until
the end of days of time okay Brock let's
go away that's fine we had you for eight
years you go away now his legacy is gone
he says this is gonna show them
leadership it's gonna show people
activism how to make a change in their
community but he but his legacy is over
his Agassiz is legacy is as empty as the
library on health care just a quick
recap of all of Barack Obama's wonderful
legacy on health care Donald Trump and
the Republicans have repealed the
individual mandate the funding mechanism
of Obamacare Obamacare was already in a
death spiral even under Obama the repeal
of its funding mechanism has sped that
up considerably
in October Donald Trump rolled back the
mandate forcing employers to pay for
abortion drugs after Barack Obama took
the Little Sisters of the Poor to court
because he was so fanatically insistent
that nuns pay for abortions Trump also
ended some Obamacare subsidies known as
cost-sharing reduction payments and he
signed an executive order opening up
competition and health insurance and
allowing some people even to purchase
health insurance across state lines
now unfortunately they haven't yet
whipped the votes to fully repeal
Obamacare and they should and they
should do it as quickly as possible the
u.s. by the way has never once repealed
a major entitlement program passed
through Congress but the White House and
Congress have chipped away at it
considerably we may still yet make
history on immigration Trump is looking
to phase out Obama's unconstitutional
executive amnesty known as daca even if
the US doesn't deport 800,000 of the
most press friendly illegal aliens
made-for-television and probably we
won't dhaka
still could be used as a bargaining chip
for wall funding and other immigration
reform Trump has cracked down on
sanctuary cities illegal immigration is
dropped within the last year to a
17-year low Republicans have scrapped
every single bit of Obama's
environmental legacy including the
disastrous clean power plan the Paris
climate Accord bans on the Keystone XL
and Dakota access pipelines we've also
opened up more federal land to private
use trumps EPA is on track to cut 47
percent of all employees by the end of
its first term for almost half of the
EPA employees will be gone just for a
retirement Nutrition by the end of the
first term on campuses of Betsy Davos
has repealed Obama era regulations
giving universities absurd control over
student sex and the investigation of sex
crimes Obama regulations forcing schools
to let men into the girls bathroom are
gone to remember how for like a year or
two we had to just talk about the
bathrooms because Barack Obama didn't
want to focus on the economy which he
couldn't manage to recover even after
eight years Obama's policy of net
neutrality remember that one government
regulation of the Internet has been
repealed ironically by an Obama
appointee at the FCC on foreign policy
unfortunately the Iran deal still
remains in place but Obama's policy of
negotiating with Cuba by giving them
everything in exchange for nothing has
been curtailed particularly after Cuban
commies responded to Obama's weakness by
attacking our diplomats with a sonar
weapon we still need to finish off
Obamacare we need to scrap the Iran deal
but overall not bad for one year
the legacy destroying lesson Obama
learned too late too late for his
library too late for his legacy and it's
a warning for president Trump and
Republicans that which can be enacted by
a pen and a phone can be repealed by a
pen and a phone so get working in
Congress and speaking of deals we talked
about all these deals we got to talk
about a new sponsor we have a new way to
keep the lights on around here which I'm
always very pleased about but this is a
product that I've actually used for
years so as I was glad to see them come
on board this is an app called honey
it's a browser extension it's completely
free I like things that are free that's
I've been using it for years my step
brother who's a was very involved in
internet ad space and Ad Exchange
servers he's always up to date on the
newest browser extensions he showed me
this honey just saves you money you pay
nothing and honey will get you money
automatically it's a free browser
extension it's used by millions and
millions of people to save money every
single day so it's the single most
popular money-saving browser add-on it
works on all major browsers Chrome
Firefox Safari and it's always free you
don't put down a credit card you don't
put none of that
it's just saving you money so how does
it work takes two clicks to add honey to
your browser the literally just two then
it starts working in the background
right away so while you shop you go on
wherever Amazon or wherever you do your
online shopping honey scans and tests
millions of coupon codes all over the
Internet to find you the biggest
discount of on in everything you buy so
you don't even in the old days you would
Google you'd be on whatever website I go
on to like stogies com or whatever and
then iGoogle I said where is the coupon
that I can find okay 20% does that work
oh no that only worked until yesterday I
type it in and you end up wasting 15 20
minutes trying to find a coupon honey
just does all of that so it no more
googling the best part is whenever
you're ready to check out honey
automatically applies the best coupon to
your cart so it's just running in the
background that means you'll always get
the biggest discount to the best price
available even without having to do
anything almost 10 million people use
honey every day to save millions and
millions of dollars why not you if it
sounds too good to be true
Time magazine agrees with this they call
honey basically free money and it is
I've used it for years I continue to use
it all the time I you know this
Christmas season I couldn't tell you
which ones I used with honey it probably
be easier to know which purchases I
didn't make with honey because you get
so many of these coupon codes that
especially during Christmas there are a
gazillion ones over the Internet no one
has time for that it's the 21st century
just get the browser extension there is
no reason not to add honey to your
browser it's free it will save you cash
on everything that you were going to buy
anyway if you're not using honey when
you shop you're missing out on
free money and so do it right now join
honey calm and how are you going to get
it you have to go to honey calm / co f
f/a Co V Fe Fe
honey calm / cough FA Co V Fe Fe
what is it Marshall Coface Co V of EF e
okay before okay we got to get to the
mailbag before we get to the mailbag I
do have one news story we have to talk
about I have to point it out because
it's a personal one Google is really
going after us right now this this
report came out Tuesday the Daily Caller
reported Google is now displaying
left-wing fact-check websites in a fully
separate sidebar on our Google results
so when you look for daily wire these
fake fact check websites come up on and
try to debunk all of our stuff article
by article and they don't do this for
the left they don't do this for voxcom
for voxcom they have a sidebar and what
does it list Fox com articles what you
would expect for us they have a sidebar
listing articles from only leftist
websites so Google is so far only
targeting for websites all conservative
it's us The Daily Caller Breitbart and
the Federalists they are in targeting
left-wing sites like Huffington Post or
Slater or Media Matters or Think
Progress and coincidentally or not the
top left-wing fact check on daily wire
as of yesterday was rebutting claims
made by the the worst heretics the
global warming skeptics people like
Richard linson the MIT atmospheric
physicist that I had on the show on
Tuesday deniers as the left calls them
and but and speaking of linson YouTube
owned by Google D monetize that video I
don't know if you caught the
conversation it was the entire
conversation that I had with Professor
linson was dry it was academic it was
about statistical inaccuracies it was it
was one of the dryer
you know episodes I've ever done there
wasn't a whole lot of khofifah it was
really analyzing science but a physicist
from MIT is too much wrong thing for
YouTube and Google so we contested this
when they demonetised it we called them
up and we said you have to turn this
money back on this is this doesn't
violate any of your standards we argued
with them back and forth
and back and forth but they said no I'm
okay well we'll turn it on for the
episode but for part of the episode that
you broke out separately we're going to
turn now we're gonna demolish that one
they also demonetised an episode we did
I did one called a Jake Tapper mean-girl
in which I explained that Jake Tapper
who used to be a journalist is a mean
girl and I dare anybody to prove my
argument wrong I think I gave a lot of
scientific evidence for that they D
monetize that too why well it you know
we don't we can't be making fun of these
left-wing hacks and these left-wing
journalists no no no so this means Media
Matters are some other leftist group or
who that is advising Google has put up
flags
even on tenured professors whose
statistical research it deems dangerous
James d'amour the guy who wrote that
Google memo he alleges that Google
managers would blacklist conservatives
and even propose trials for people who
hold conservative views now Google has a
virtual monopoly on information on the
Internet
Prager University is already suing them
for discrimination conservatives should
consider a united front it is really
getting pretty oppressive out there ok
let's get into the mailbag before we get
into the mail Marshall you're so cruel
you're so rude to them I want to keep
the mailbag on for you guys I wanted it
to remain public but unfortunately if
you're not at the Daily wire calm right
now you can't see it so if you're on
Facebook and YouTube go over to Daily
wire calm right now if you're already a
member thank you you help keep the
lights on and keep khofifah in my cup if
you subscribe this is a good deal folks
make a new year's resolution to
appropriately store your leftist tears
this year in 2018 you don't want there
to be fallout you don't want your family
to be hurt by the radioactive leftist
tears make sure that you have the proper
vessel the leftist tears tumblr oh and
you'll also get a meme Andrew Klavan in
the ben shapiro show and no ads on the
website and you get to ask questions of
the mailbag and conversation blah blah
blah but you really need this this is
just a matter of safety for your family
so go over I get the leftist ears tumblr
it is going away soon by the way well
you will not know the day or the hour
but very soon we're going to
and then no more folks you're gonna be
trying to get into our bunker to escape
the fallout so go to daily wire calm
right now we'll be right back
[Music]
okay our first question comes in from
let's see from Christian at Silva yes
question is hey Michael I'm working on a
campaign running to take the seat away
from debbie Wasserman Schultz I know
you've worked on campaigns before any
advice
sure absolutely debbie Wasserman Schultz
is the disgraced former head of the DNC
who got caught giving the whole thing
away to Hillary so yeah I have a little
bit of advice the district you're
looking at I think that's Florida
Florida 23 or something like that so I
forget the exact name of her district
that district is d plus 11 last time I
checked so things aren't looking great
for you it means that leans heavily
Democratic that said the district has
gotten more competitive mostly thanks to
debbie Wasserman Schultz so Democrats
from a 2002 to 2010 never got below 74
percent of the vote in that general
election Schultz has performed
considerably worse than her predecessor
Alcee Hastings even in 2012 Schultz only
got sixty three point two percent of the
general election vote there in the
election Pryor Hastings got seventy nine
point one percent of the vote that's a
big drop Schultz's popularity keeps
decreasing in 2014 she dropped to sixty
two point seven percent in next year she
got a fifty six point seven percent so
it's still quite a hard race to win but
the trend is in your favor at least and
her total implosion last year on the
national stage will help you now I guess
for the advice you can't just run
negative so it's easy to just run
negative on former Congresswoman jar jar
binks
you should partially run negative you
should point out her ample flaws but
nobody votes against somebody they don't
just vote against somebody it doesn't
work you need to have a clear message
and offer voters something so mitch
Daniels one of my favorite politicians
mitch daniels in indiana he won by large
margins as a republican even as Barack
Obama won by large margins as a Democrat
same year in that state he had a clear
message his campaign slogan was I want
to increase the net disposable income of
Hoosiers that's very clear I know what
I'm voting for
I'm gonna vote for that and yeah you can
knock the other guy you can run a little
negative I suppose you have to but
that's that's the message offer them
something concrete the on the national
stage the politicians who offered
something concrete and serious strong
messages those are the ones who win some
other advice for the congressional
ignore whatever Washington DC tells you
whatever the consultants and the party
people just ignore it Rudy Giuliani gave
us this advice on a congressional
campaign that I worked on a number of
years ago the people in the district are
going to win you the seat them and the
donors then DC is going to swoop in and
they're gonna screw everything up so DC
can get you some money you should take
the money if especially if some of the
campaign committees are gonna offer it
to you but if they offer you advice on
the operations
they're gonna give you cookie cutter
operations that know nothing about your
district and they're gonna lose you that
campaign it's all about the people
another thing you can do is constantly
innovate so just a short story I was on
a congressional campaign when I was 18
or 19 and it was a challenger race
against a Democrat incumbent the
incumbent was his name's John Hall and
he had been in the rock band to Orleans
in the seventies they're the guys who
did like still the one that do and they
did dance with me I want to be your
partner can't you see
so I decided as a lowly staffer on this
campaign we would start the young voters
for an Orleans reunion tour to get John
Hall back on stage and out of Congress
and we read this whole website I was
writing up and performing in these music
videos you know I kind of ripped off his
song and made it vote with me let's make
John Hall leave Washington DC and all
this it was just really funny and it
killed these guys so they couldn't
resist they threatened to sue me EMI
Music threatened to sue me John Holden
the band's John Hall himself did and it
got us a ton of press it got it made us
look innovative and cool and and we
ended up winning that campaign we won
the campaign on the strength of the
candidate and on the the movement and
the Tea Party movement behind her but it
did help it gave us a nice bit of
momentum in it and it gave us good press
so you be innovative don't don't just
think mm how can we not lose this what's
the thing that we're supposed to do
forget what you're supposed to do
politics is not won on what you're
- do you you've got to be really
innovative here so also keep the
campaign lean campaign bloat sucks up a
lot of energy and drive I know this is
unenjoyable making some pittance of a
campaign salary I've made plenty of
those but it does align incentives to
make sure that you win and the incentive
there is you get a victory bonus or you
get a legislative job so run hard run to
win and don't waste your money and
ignore the experts please including
maybe me oh that was self-defeating I'm
no expert on this I'm just a guy who's
been on campaigns that's my advice
next question from Andrew hey Michael
I'm 20 years old and I've been Catholic
since birth but for the past four to
five years I've become less religious I
don't pray anymore I don't read the
Bible I haven't been a confession in a
very long time and I'm starting to skip
Mass every Sunday but worst of all I've
let more sinfulness into my life my
question to you is how do I come back to
the Catholic Church and what are some
steps for me to get out of constant
sinfulness thank you and God bless
Andrew just do it just do it that's this
the nike advice just do it I'm with you
I was completely out of it for probably
a decade or at least the better part of
a decade I think a full decade and so
the way the the thing that got me back
in is I was convinced that God exists
and then I was convinced that Jesus is
who he says he is and it all followed
from there I was convinced of that by a
few things some by arguments the
arguments for the existence of God some
by writing apologetic writing like CS
Lewis and like Chesterton and others and
and then there is the numinous
experience you do have the experience of
the world I remember once I didn't
remember this until just now I was
smoking a cigar and looking at it some
plants in my yard that I I was I don't
know a teenager and I thought something
clicked into my mind that pure
rationalism that my ideological view of
the world in my a theistic view it
didn't explain these things it didn't
explain my experience of the world as I
knew it to be so that's a little bit
more of the religious or spiritual or
numinous experience that you would have
but do it and replevin has a good
youtube video on how to find God in 60
days which is to behave as though God
exists
if you do believe all of that then that
that is going to work on your body
no now plenty of saints went through
great periods of darkness mother Teresa
herself writes about a lot of these
things so I wouldn't let the not that
not the constant emotional feeling of
God I wouldn't let that discourage you
you know the angel Gabriel came down to
Mary said Mary you're blessed above all
women God Himself is gonna be born out
of your womb isn't that great she says
well I'm the servant of the Lord let it
happen but then the angel went away and
then Mary went on with her life and it's
not like God was constantly saying that
rah rah riding this great Mary went on
with her life in it and had much
difficulty in had to cry as her son bled
on the cross and died so the we see this
throughout the Bible it's not like God
is just constantly in a chit-chatting
with us but he does intervene at times
so I wish you luck on your spiritual
journey I would say keep your keep your
eyes in some of these words for me
because the temptation of my age and my
place in the United States was this
intellectualized
temptation the temptation of being at a
university and being young and from the
Northeast so I've kind of found my way
back a little bit through analytical
philosophy and very intelligent
apologists a go where that go where your
temptation is I would say you know
whatever your temptation is find the
Christian and the Catholic answer to
that and I think that'll put you put you
right back on the right path but I wish
you luck pal god bless from Nicholas
dear Michael I am a Catholic I'm shocked
we're getting these Catholic questions
we never get these I am Catholic my
girlfriend is a Protestant she's been
asking me many questions about the many
different things that are important to
the Catholic faith like why the Virgin
Mary is so important and why priests are
able to forgive sins I have a very basic
understanding of why these are but I
want to learn more do you have any books
that you would recommend reading so that
a simpleton like me can get a deeper
understanding of topics like these so I
can answer my girlfriend's questions
better thanks for all that you do you
handsome Italian thanks Nick appreciate
that priests can forgive sins because
Jesus says so most clearly in John 23
and
through 1619 but in other places too and
Mary is so important because she's the
mother of God I suppose we could talk
more about that but I think those those
answers are sufficient if you're looking
for a good resource I don't think you're
simple-minded especially because you
called me a good-looking Italian but if
if you do want a simple indirect
resource there's a great one called
Catholic Answers so if you if you want
answers to Catholicism Catholic Answers
is a good name for it and they have the
answers to everything the Catholic
Church has been around for a very long
time and so they've thought about a lot
of things you can go there and then I
recommend also reading as much as you
can of Agustin and Thomas Aquinas some
of the church fathers and that patristic
era and you'll see you know a lot of
people just start reading things that
were written after the Protestant
revolution so they learn a lot of things
that aren't exactly so and they're
responding to arguments from only one
particular time I think the church
fathers are priests aging they're seeing
in advance the or some of the arguments
that will come up that we see in
modernity and they'll explain to you why
practices and rituals and theology has
developed as it has so the easy answer
is Catholic answers and the probably
more edifying one in the long run or is
that patristic era and Agustin and later
Aquinas from Benjamin hey Michael this
was a long time ago but I noticed you
catching flack from a lot of Philistines
on Facebook regarding the movie Lady
Bird people were upset that you endorsed
what they thought as lewd and
pornographic as a Christian movie not to
rail against my fellow Christians and
conservatives go for buddy
as I'm sure they mean well but do you
think attitudes like these contribute to
the inability of Christian and
conservative art to break through the
culture sorry for bad wording I'm an
engineer not a writer let's face it
movies like fireproof and God's not dead
flat-out are not very good
despite the talent of those involved why
can't we make good art why can't we have
nice things this is a very long question
let's answer what we have so far so this
is something we struggle with all the
time we struggled with it even I'm doing
another
with Andrew Klavan his his book that he
wrote that we're now releasing as a
podcast and I'm performing it but it's
got naughty words and some saucy scenes
and we have people write in sometimes
and they say you call yourself a
Christian the I really like Lady Bird I
thought it was the best movie of last
year and relatively it was a quite a
good movie and it is quite Christian
it's Christian through a beginning
middle and end the protagonists name is
a reference to Christ but for those
people who think that Christianity is
just good manners and being polite and
listening to some of that god-awful
acoustic guitar music that they play at
modern churches you've got to read that
Bible you've got to go back and read
your Bible the the scenes from just
Genesis alone would never fit that
criteria if you could never produce
Genesis by those criteria there is sex
and incest and fire and brimstone and
cheating and lying of the protagonists
have been some protagonists doing a lot
of this stuff so you have to perceive
reality as it is the truth above all
things Christianity is not just some
little sect and some nice feel-good
philosophy that doesn't have a reference
to truth it's true it perceives the
world and so if we try to change the
world we're gonna fall into a saccharine
sentimental religion that is no good CS
Lewis said if you look for comfort you
might find truth there ray if you look
for truth you might find comfort but if
you look for comfort you'll find a
neither truth nor comfort only soft soap
and wishful thinking to begin and in the
end despair so don't don't be brought
into the saccharine and the sentimental
I think of those paintings that were
popular in the 2000s Thomas Kinkade the
painter of lights everything's so nice
and sentimental I like all that stuff
too but you've got to perceive reality
our Lord lived in reality and he dealt
in reality and he dealt with the woman
at the well and he dealt with
prostitutes and money called tax
collectors you got a deal on that
reality and I hope that I hope some
Philistines get on board with it but hey
we can just keep making the art and
you know another Kingdom is done very
well that we're having trouble in
Hollywood not among the popular audience
so I think maybe the culture is changing
a bit away from that sentimentalism from
Laura Huber my fiance and I are in our
mid-twenties and excited to start a
family together we recently watched a
movie called Eyes Wide Shut hedging our
bets that Kubrick might be worth
watching turns out it's about a wealthy
men sex cult the next day I
serendipitously came across an article
from Vanity Fair called
oh my god this is so effed up inside
Silicon Valley's secretive orgy astok
darkside which details popular sex and
drug fueled parties that wealthy tech
founders host the author on feminist not
moral rents denounces the orgies but the
male participants claimed this is
another great way in which their great
minds challenge convention and it makes
up for their late entry into sex life so
there's a lot on YouTube about polyamory
what do you say of the future of this
undercurrent in society and of
monogamous marriage you just got to do
you I mean these things always come up
especially in decadent cultures like
ours cultures where the moral strictures
a go away but they they've always
existed there was plenty of weird sex in
the Victorian era and certainly on
college campuses that that's always been
the case Lord make me chase but not yet
isn't it is an ancient maxim and what I
would say though having been out here in
la-la land in the heart of darkness I
have noticed this I know a lot of people
who have open relationships open
marriages polyamory and they cheat on
their girlfriend and the girlfriend
sheets on them whatever I've never met
anyone who does that who's happy I've
never met anyone who does that who's
fulfilled or pleased it seems like you
would be until people get sex Austin
this is a phenomena I've observed it's
sex Austin meaningless trivial sex with
a bunch of random people and it isn't
fulfilling in the long run so as a as a
matter of culture it will ebb and flow
and you'll get some of that I think
smart people will realize it's not good
in the long term and not fulfilling to
them but but it that will always be
around and it's hopefully we can hope
for them and pray for them and try to
teach them people who do that that
it isn't good it just doesn't turn out
well so maybe to avoid it but good luck
to you and your your fiancee from
William hey mr. Noles my name is Bill
and I'm a young practicing Catholic
however my girlfriend of two years is a
practicing Mormon I get a lot of
different comments on whether or not our
marriage will work in the future but I
personally feel like it won't be an
issue with the exception of the question
of what to raise our children if we have
any we really have had a good and
healthy relationship and openly discuss
our differences in belief what I'd like
to know is do you think that a marriage
can be successful if the two individuals
have a strong faith in two different
religions Sincerely Yours bill yes with
a caveat yes it can be successful I
think if with people who have strong
religious views I've seen it work very
well in that case and by the way you
review is my change over time people's
views change over time I have friends
who have converted from religions who
have converted from Mormonism actually
or friends who have become atheists or
people have gone out of being and I was
sort of an atheist for a long time
so I wouldn't worry about that except
for the kids except for the raising of
kids that issue is going to be probably
intractable and you don't want to
confuse the kids and have them one day
think one thing and then be told the
opposite is true and you know this
parent is gonna go to hell or this
parent is gonna go to hell you you
really should decide with the children
first and that doesn't mean that you're
you or your fiancee need to convert to
anything but you should decide and if
you think that you have the vision the
correct vision of reality then do it a
lot of my Mormon friends say you know
this is just a version of Christianity
maybe you raise the kids in what CS
Lewis calls mere christianity there
there are ways to work around I don't
think you need to dump dump one another
but you should solve that problem
because it would be a real shame to get
into the situation say we'll work it out
later and then you get to the most
important aspect of marriage the
creation of family and you fight and you
have to break up or something that would
be that would be a real shame so figure
that one out and otherwise yeah I think
you can work for everything else from
Norman dear Archbishop Thomas Michael
Knowles I have been giving a lot of
consideration to the Catholic faith and
already to some degree consider myself a
small C Catholic so your argument
about God creating a particular church
with a particular clergy resonated with
me but I have also heard the opposite
side argued well from members of my
evangelical family they say that God's
particular people was Israel and that
the church is described by way of
contrast as Universal Jesus the
particular man fulfilled the Messianic
prophecies to Israel whereas Christ the
universal logos of the universe is head
of the church they quote to McDonald
Trump they go at 2 Corinthians at 2nd
Corinthians 5:16 we once regarded Christ
according to the flesh we regard him
thus no longer what do you make of their
claim against the particular
particularity and for the universality
of church what do you think st. Paul is
saying in that verse I think you're
confusing universality for abstraction
there is a universal Church the word
Catholic means universal but the church
is not an abstraction Christ is not an
abstraction the paragraph you cite reads
quote for we know that if the temps that
is our earthly home is destroyed we have
a building from God a house not made
with hands eternal in the heavens for in
this tent we groan longing to put on our
heavenly dwelling if indeed by putting
it on we may not be found naked we would
rather be away from the body and at home
with the Lord for we must all appear
before the judgment seat of Christ so
that each one may receive what is due
for what he has done in the body whether
good or evil from now on therefore we
regard no one according to the flesh
even though we once regarded Christ
according to the flesh we regard him
thus no longer we regard no one
according to the flesh because Christ's
conquest of death gives us the hope of
eternal life of being eternal beings but
that does not mean Christ can be
abstracted from his incarnation this is
the temptation of rationalism it's a
political temptation it's a
philosophical temptation and a religious
one Martin Luther wrote in matters of
faith each Christian is for himself Pope
in church it's no coincidence that
rationalism a Rove
of the Protestant revolution by
rationalism I mean that elevation of
each man's capacity to reason
now one man's reason his intellect and
his will are perfect that man is Christ
but the rest of ours are not we see the
themes of emancipation and revolution
running throughout modernity but we
should be careful when we overthrow in
these revolutions what we emancipate
ourselves from so the rationalist
exercise continually distinguishes the
symbol from the symbolized it separates
them you can only comprehend abstract
things so the rationalist thinks in ever
more abstract terms but Christ is not
abstract there is no separation between
Jesus the man in Christ the logos Christ
is that unity he says it is the spirit
who gives life and he says this bread is
my body and this is a hard saying and
only those who eat my flesh and drink my
blood have life in them he is heaven
touching earth the perfect junction of
the symbol and the symbolized we groan
to throw off this life but we are not
merely spirit were merely flesh our
particular selves comprise inextricably
body and soul this is therefore the
claim of the church there is no disunity
between the particularity and the
universality of the church as the Nicene
Creed States clearly there is one Holy
Catholic and Apostolic Church and her
bridegroom is Christ a man who was born
2,000 years ago to a woman named Mary in
Bethlehem and who existed before all
ages who in the beginning is with God
and is God I do want to go back just one
quite a bit it just occurred to me on
the the question about the Mormon yes so
I'm sorry I was I was confused I thought
that bill is a practicing in that
previous question bill is a practicing
Protestant and his girlfriend of two
years is a Mormon bill is actually a
Catholic and I should note in this
answer the Catholic Church before it
will give a dispensation for interfaith
marriage requires that you say that you
will raise the children Catholic and
there isn't any getting around that so
you'll either have to do that or lie to
the church which is probably not a good
way to start your life together in a
sacrament it that that does make it
harder than if you were a Protestant or
a mere Christian and CS Lewis right but
you should you should be aware of that I
don't want
I don't want to spread any fake news on
this show from Jeremiah mr. Austin
lively Knowles king of trolls I'm
enjoying another Kingdom but it has
raised a couple of questions in my mind
do you have any standards when it comes
to acting I have no standards at all
when it come to of what you will not do
be it language or nudity for a role for
example if you were offered a role in
something like Game of Thrones but it
required graphic nudity and sex scenes
would you do it why are why not thanks
Jeremiah I have no standards at all no
that's not quite true I would take a
role in Game of Thrones in a second I
would do nudity I would do language I
would do whatever if the art were good
or I would do it if it served an
artistic purpose and were beautiful and
showed something to the world beyond
just little Michael just a mega lute so
so I once was on an audition out here in
LA for I don't know some indie film and
the role required a nude bathroom scene
and I said okay that's fine I guess they
said the guy the guy doing the interview
or the audition rather said okay and
it's going to be a gay scene I said okay
that's if it serves the story and the
story's a good one let's do it he said
okay and I'm gonna be playing the other
guy said well you know that's a bridge
too far that that I've read about these
stories and The Hollywood Reporter and
me too and all this so I wouldn't do it
if it were to ative stupid and
pornographic but as long as the story is
serving a purpose then obviously it's
it's important to do the beautiful thing
and to create the art and to show
reality as it is which is not always
beautiful but at that that's where the
the purpose of it really matters and and
it has to go story by story and Game of
Thrones I don't even care for it
particularly but that's a that's an
artistic show there is quite a lot of
art there so I'd do it in a second if
you're watching casting directors give
me a call I'm here for you
okay next question no that's the last
question okay great so we're gonna end
on yes I will be naked on camera I can't
wait to do it give me a call that is our
entire show I hope that you survive the
weekend speaking of the clayvin last
weekend the penultimate episode of
another kingdom comes out tomorrow
morning and
Friday so tune in for that things are
wrapping up it's a lot of a lot of fun
things are coming together and the
please send it to your friends it really
really pleases me and makes me so happy
when we can stick a fork right Nollywood
zai please please go over do that
download it wherever good narrative
fantasy podcasts about schlubs in
Hollywood who make it into another
universe with bloody daggers and dead
damsels wherever those are downloaded
you can get and reclaim its another
Kingdom
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show have a good weekend I'll see
you Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
Hague
supervising producer Mathis Glover our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex's and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Jeshua alvera the Michael nul show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2017